Buzzy HBO shows, Universal monster movies,
and an unusual Suicide Squad role. It's obvious
why Riley in "The Last of Us" looks so familiar.
In Season 1, Episode 6 of HBO's "The
Last of Us," Joel ends up taking a
nasty piece of wood to the abdomen, and
Ellie wonders if her newly adopted father
will survive. Judging by almost every
encounter the duo has had in the past,
the odds don't exactly look good in Ellie's
eyes. Basically, if there was ever a time for
a reprieve from the relentlessness of
"The Last of Us," that moment is now.
Giving the audience a breather
from Joel's harrowing present,
Episode 7 tells Ellie's backstory. Raised in the
FEDRA run military school, there's little room for
freedom. However, Ellie does form a friendship
with another student named Riley – who ends up
leaving her to join the Fireflies. While the
Fireflies are dubbed a terrorist organization,
Riley is important to Ellie. In this world,
friends are few and far between. Unsurprisingly,
a young actor who has already appeared in
many high-profile projects was selected to
take on one of the most important
roles in "The Last of Us" so far.
"Well I appreciate your mercy."
As a child, Storm Reid was no stranger to acting,
but it was her leading role in "A Wrinkle In
Time" which set her up for success, and saw her
starring alongside Chris Pine, Oprah Winfrey,
Reese Witherspoon, and Mindy Kaling. "A Wrinkle
In Time" is known to many because it is based
on a classic science fiction children's book.
Written in the 1960s by Madeleine L’Engle, the
story was the start of a five-book series about
Meg Murry and the search for her missing father.
2018's feature film wasn't the
first time the book was adapted,
but it did break many barriers in the process.
With "Selma" director Ava DuVernay at the helm,
the film gives an alternate perspective to a
book that was released over half a century ago.
Casting Reid in the lead role contrasted with
previous adaptations, and was a significant
step for representation. Even though DuVernay
theorized that not everyone would appreciate
the casting of a young girl of color in the
leading role, many found merit in the final
product. Despite the fact that the film received
mixed reviews, it remains a beautiful and sweeping
story that stays true to the book. Reid would
later reunite with DuVernay in 2019 for the
director's acclaimed limited series "When
They See Us," based on the tragedy of the
Central Park Five. In that project, she played
Lisa, the real-life girlfriend of Korey Wise.
The Universal Monster universe never really took
off, but Leigh Whannell deserves respect for
his updated version of classic movie "The
Invisible Man." Starring Elisabeth Moss,
the 2020 film follows one woman's attempts to
rid herself of abusive ex-boyfriend Adrian,
who just so happens to be a tech genius.
The insidious abuse that Cecilia experienced
during their relationship was so severe that
she doesn't believe it when she's told
that Adrian has died from suicide.
Unfortunately for her and those around
her, she is proven right when Adrian
resurfaces with technology that allows
him to be invisible. Everyone suffers,
especially Sydney, played by Storm Reid,
the daughter of Cecilia's friend James.
Adrian hits Sydney when only Cecilia is in the
room, framing her for the attack. Sydney is the
ultimate innocent in the situation, unable
to understand what happened to her. Cecilia
eventually gets the better of her ex at the end
of "The Invisible Man," but not before so much
damage is done. Reid doesn't have a large amount
of screen time, but she does exemplary work,
and displays heartbreaking emotion in one of the
most uncomfortable scenes in the entire movie.
DC's 2021 reboot of 2016's "Suicide Squad"
came with many surprises, both delightful
and heartwrenching. After his Marvel tenure,
James Gunn arrived in the director's chair to
keep what worked from the previous film and
set everything else on fire. In a wise move,
he kept Margot Robbieas Harley Quinn and Joel
Kinnaman as Rick Flagg for an all-new adventure.
Opting to remove Jared Leto's Joker and the
character's controversial relationship with Harley
from "The Suicide Squad," Gunn instead decided to
tell a universal story about the power of family.
"We're all going to die."
"I hope so."
At the center of this story is
Bloodsport, played by Idris Elba,
who is in prison for trying to kill Superman.
As if that wasn't enough to prove he's no hero,
he also happens to be a terrible father.
Because of his past with his own father,
Bloodsport pushes away his daughter Tyla, who is
played by Reid, when she visits him in prison.
But underneath it all, he does care for her.
In fact, Amanda Waller blackmails Bloodsport
into joining the Suicide Squad because
of his love for his daughter. And through
all his trials and tribulations, he takes
one step closer to being a worthy father.
HBO's hit teen drama "Euphoria" stars
Zendaya as drug-addicted high schooler Rue,
and the series focuses on the
sharpest experiences of growing up.
"Class of '26 is like obsessed with 'Euphoria.'"
Relationships are at the center of the series,
and that includes the conflict Rue has with
her family. In Season 2, Rue has a dramatic
relapse which culminates in a harrowing scene
between her and her sister Gia, who is played
by Reid. While the sisters have a profound bond,
the foundation of their relationship is
shaken to its core. At such a young age,
Reid demonstrates that she has an acting
range on par with her Emmy-winning co-star.
Discussing her offscreen relationship
with Zendaya, Reid told Elle Australia,
"It's important to have some conversations and get
to know a person before you are doing
these emotional scenes with a person."
With so many incredible
performances under her belt,
Reid's star is only going to rise further
following her appearance on "The Last of Us."